wer sich freuen nach zwei jahren corona
wieder zu reisen der wird schnell
ausgebremst die züge sind voll das
benzin ist teurer berufspendler
verzweifeln an baustellen und auch die
pünktlichkeit der bahn ist kein verlass
sommer fahrten mit dem neuen euro ticket
könnten zum abenteuer werden wenn das
ticket überhaupt noch kommt drei
bundesländer drohen mit blockade im
bundesrat
dabei meint die politik ist ja gut sie
will den bürger entlasten und dabei
etwas für das klima tun die probleme der
mobilität die lassen sich so einfach
aber nicht lösen warten im stau warten
am gleis wann kommt die verkehrswende
unser thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen hier aus berlin ich darf mir
meine gäste vorstellen bernd reuther ist
bei uns verkehrspolitischer sprecher der
fdp bundestagsfraktion und kandidat auch
seiner fraktion für den aufsichtsrat der
deutschen bahn und mit derselben
funktion aber nicht unbedingt derselben
ansicht sitzt hier stefan gelbhaar von
bündnis 90/die grünen
verkehrspolitischer sprecher eben und
auch kandidat für den aufsichtsrat der
bahn
zugeschaltet ist das siebte zimmer sie
ist stellvertretende direktorin der
agora verkehrswende das ist eine
denkfabrik zum thema mobilität und
klimaschutz
und herzlich willkommen thomas puls erst
zehn jahre kondom ist für verkehr und
infrastruktur beim arbeitgebernahe
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut
iwb in
kräuter egal mit wem ich gesprochen habe
dass wir dieses thema besprechen heute
in der phoenix runde jeder hatte eine
geschichte dazu was alles schief läuft
in diesem land wenn man unterwegs sein
will egal ob mit der bahn oder mit dem
auto wie kommt das wo sind wo stehen wir
was die mobilität betrifft in diesem
land ja das geht ihnen genauso wie mir
ich werde auch dauernd angesprochen von
menschen die im stau stehen von menschen
die an bahnsteigen stehen oder auch
sogar an flughäfen
weil die flieger verspätung haben und
die flughäfen nicht von vernünftig
funktionieren wir müssen und das hat
sich ja die aktuelle bundesregierung und
die ampel koalition vorgenommen viel
investieren in die
infrastruktur in unserem land in den op
en v in die schiene aber auch in marode
straßen und brücken das heißt aber das
dauert alles und wir müssen noch ganz
lange mit diesem status quo jetzt leben
wir
werden da noch eine zeit mit leben
müssen aber ein zweiter ganz wichtiger
punkt ist dass wir dass die koalition
sich das thema planungs beschleunigung
und schnelleres bauen und schnelleres
ausbauen in allen infrastruktur
bereichen ja auch ganz groß auf die
fahnen geschrieben haben das eine
bedingt das andere wenn wir in den in
dem tempo der vergangenen jahre und
jahrzehnte weiter machen wird das noch
sehr lange dauern und das wollen wir
nicht
herr gelb der anteil der pünktlichen
züge wenn man mal bei der bahn erst mal
bleiben also der ec und ic züge der
deutschen bahn der iss im april unter
die marke von 70 prozent auf 69 prozent
gerutscht wie kommt es zu diesem
negativrekord
ja wir haben verschiedene baustellen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes bei der bahn
das ist eine davon und die hat multiple
gründe zum einen das system ist nicht
resident genug also wenn irgendwo im
bahnsystem da irgendwie eine verspätung
ist ein zug hängen bleibt oder eine
baustelle unerwartet
ausgeweitet wo ist ein baum umfällt was
auch immer ist das nicht bloß eine
lokale störung sondern kann sich sehr
schnell ins gesamtsystem
fortsetzen und da mal gucken dass wir
das abgestellt bekommen mit eben mehr
angebot also mehr züge wurden das
abfedern kann besser umsteige relationen
abbilden kann und eben auch eine einer
stelle mein weiteres gleis damit eben
dann so ein problem auch nicht umfahren
aber daran vorbeigefahren werden kann
das ist viel arbeit aber auch das etwas
was noch lange daran wird ja also neue
gleise zu bauen und dauert das die
gleiche variante also warum sollte man
dann genauer muss ist noch eine andere
frage das hat der kollege schon leute
das wird dabei der planungs
beschleunigung der einfach schneller
werden müssen was elektrifizierung so
weiter angeht aber es ist auch eine
frage von effizienz und effektivität von
einem system also sagen wir mal wenn die
schiene digital wäre und wir schneller
erkennen können da kann ein problem
auftreten deswegen auch schneller
reagieren könnten oder die bahn auch das
dürfte helfen nicht an jeder stelle aber
noch an der einen oder anderen
impuls man fragt sich ja viele leute die
unterwegs sind mit der bahn die sagen
mir wir sind doch so ein wichtiges
starkes industrieland wie kann das sein
dass bei uns diese infrastruktur die
bahn dass das alles so nicht
funktioniert viele vergleichen ist
natürlich mit japan auf vielleicht aber
auch mit frankreich was ist da ja ihre
ihre erklärung aus wirtschafts sicht wo
sie sagen was ist da eigentlich
schiefgelaufen
nation ist man muss man glaube ich sagen
dass japan und frankreich kein guter
vergleich sind ins beide länder zeichnen
sich zum beispiel dadurch aus dass sie
praktisch nur schienenpersonenverkehr
haben wir haben halt auch jede menge
güterverkehr und da läuft das system
natürlich sehr schwierig zusammen also
ich möchte erstmal eine lanze für die
deutsche bahn brechen weil wir machen
hier eben alles güterverkehr
personenverkehr aber und das das führt
dazu dass wir halt auch mehr probleme
haben aber ich glaube wirklich ein punkt
den wir hier machen müssen gerade im
hinblick darauf dass wir im november
schon fast vor dem kollaps des
güterverkehrs gesprochen haben auf der
schiene wir müssen mehr in die richtung
gehen gerade im bahnbereich auch
europäisch zu denken die bahn ist ein
langstrecken transportmittel gerade im
güterverkehr und da müssen wir wirklich
besser werden pro zimmer wie sehen sie
es so sagen sie gibt es möglichkeiten
haben es eben von 1 reuter gehört auch
von der gelb alle ideen dauern ja die
infrastruktur zu verbessern das wird ja
dauernd gibt es punkte wo sie sagen da
könnte man ansetzen jetzt schnell das
system etwas zu entlasten
wir fangen und zwar ist wir sehen da
kann ich die themensetzung der letzten
jahre oder jahrzehnte ist es einfach
nicht genug in die infrastruktur
investiert worden und versteht deshalb
ist und deswegen angesprochen jetzt
kommen auch dadurch stark zustande das
nehme ich mit der sanierung begonnen
damit vom verzögerung standard und was
ganz wichtig ist für die zukunft wohl
der erste schritt mit dem deutschlandtag
gemacht worden ist also
deutschlandpaktes so neil bild wie soll
im jahr 2013 20 30 plus aussehen seit
gefahren die das farbsehen nach sinkt
man gibt auf eine klare zielvorstellung
wohin koalitionsvertrag steht ist die
rede von einer top verdopplung der
personenverkehrs nachfrage und
entsprechend müssen jetzt die
investitionen anstoßen werden ungefragt
er tatsächlich
realisiert
reuter wie soll das denn funktionieren
da steht ja tatsächlich im
koalitionsvertrag das 260 millionen
menschen sollen jährlich in die
fernverkehrszüge umsteigen ist das ein
realistisches ziel warum kann man das
anpacken also es ist ein glaub schon
realistisches aber auch ambitioniertes
ziel was was da gesetzt wird vom thema
angesprochen der deutschland pakt ist da
ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt die wir
können die menschen in unserem land nur
von der bahn überzeugen
wenn sie fährt wenn sie pünktlich fährt
wenn die anschlüsse funktionieren wenn
der umstadt und stieg in den nahverkehr
gut funktioniert gerade gerade im
ländlichen raum dass das sind die punkte
das ding ist aber den leuten heute sind
ja nicht von der bahn überzeugt dass
wollen ganz viel mit der bahn fahren
aber die züge sind brechend voll und
wenn ich versuche einen bahn an entzug
zu buchen dann kann ich ganz viele züge
gar nicht buch und weil sie ausverkauft
sind also eigentlich sind die menschen
doch also ist die bahn doch jetzt schon
an ihrer grenze
kollege gelb hat hier angesprochen wir
brauchen natürlich auch mehr züge wir
brauchen mehr kapazitäten im netz das
netz ist voll herr puls hat ja auch zu
recht auf das thema güterverkehr
hingewiesen das ist natürlich ganz
anders zu betrachten als in anderen
ländern wo es wirklich fast
ausschließlich personenverkehr gibt hier
fahren und das ist ja auch ein wichtiges
wichtiger punkt mehr güter von der
straße auf die schiene zu bekommen und
die ich umgekehrt aber wenn sie noch
mehr güter auf die schiene kommen
belassen sie das ja noch mehr deswegen
muss auch das netz ausgebaut werden dass
schneller aufgebaut werden bei mir durch
den wahlkreis läuft die sogenannte
betuwe linie
das ist eine gut zusätzliches gleis für
güterverkehr vom hafen rotterdam ins
ruhrgebiet der staatsvertrag mit den
niederlanden ist 992 dazu unterzeichnet
worden und wir sind hier immer noch beim
planfeststellungsverfahren und die auf
niederländischer seite ist sie auch seit
15 jahren fertig und um mal so ein
zeigen wie die dimensionen hier so sind
und da müssen wir wirklich an alle
stellschrauben run von vorne bis hinten
von von der planung von anfang an die
menschen mitnehmen bis sind dann auch zu
schnell bauen wie kann das funktionieren
also ich wir sind uns einig dass wir
mehr brauchen und dass es schneller
gehen muss aber noch mal die frage
müssen wir damit leben dass wir noch die
nächsten zehn jahre alt ebenso ein
problem haben wo wir ja auch noch die
co2 ziele erreichen wollen
lasst uns das gegenmittel reden wir
brauchen einen quasi ein paar
jahrzehnten so will das heißt da muss
personal rein da muss geld rein also
einfach politisch muster der wilde
hinter ich glaube dass im bundestag
insgesamt bei allen parteien
zu konzertieren jetzt keine abneigung
gegen bahn ist sich die frage ist wie
stark dreht man das ventil auf und sagt
das ist unser fokus da gehen wir jetzt
drauf als politik aber auch von der bahn
selbst ja wir brauchen neue züge ja wir
brauchen auch neue verbindungen und so
weiter aber wir müssen auch mit den
bestehenden systemen einfach schauen wie
kriegen das effizienter wie kriegen was
stabiler so auch das sind ja
faktoren die die attraktivität bestimmen
und ich sag mal so wenn wir die chance
nummer die schiene digitalisierten dann
holen wir die entscheidenden prozente
und zwar nicht eins oder zwei sondern
zehn bis zwanzig raus wo wir einfach
mehr züge fahren das reden was muss ich
mir darunter dann vorstellen stellen
sich einfach vor man weiß wo ein
güterzug ist man weiß wo der personenzug
ist wo oder regionalzug ist und man kann
die eggert akten enger kombinieren und
dadurch einfach mehr das gleis nutzen
das ist die idee dahinter ist banal
formuliert und dann würde
er wurde auch etwas schneller da der
qualitätssprung oder der qualitätsgewinn
zu bemerken sein weil digitalisierung
ist auch infrastruktur ist jetzt auch
nicht so dass vom himmel fällt ist aber
jetzt nicht unbedingt an jeder stelle
mit meinen langjährigen planverfahren
verbunden aber auch lag das ja noch
angehen
daher ist diese koalition glaube ich
berufen gerufen und eigentlich auch
genau die richtige koalition um zu sagen
okay das ziehen wir uns an wir müssen
wir jetzt aber im nächsten jahr die
gelder bereitstellen damit dass dann
losgehen kann also es ist nicht nur eine
geldfrage aber eben auch eine geldfrage
das ist also ein digitalisierungs schub
da brauchst du auch die richtigen leute
früher da musst du menschen für
begeistern das sind neue jobs die dann
auch bei der bahn gemacht werden müssen
ja das gebraucht zum setting dafür
braucht es will und da das ist
anstrengend und das kabel gut wenn frau
zimmer in ihrem job kümmern sie sich ja
sozusagen um die mobilität und natürlich
um die klimawende es wird ja zusammen
gedacht was muss denn solche zusagen der
treiber sein wenn wir darüber reden wie
wir mobilität mobilität in diesem land
organisieren ist das wichtigste weniger
co2 auszustoßen schnell von a nach b zu
kommen was ist der punkt wo sie sagen
das muss immer das erste kriterium sein
also ganz wesentlich ist natürlich
sechsten mal stürzt wir haben
klimaschutzziele in deutschland jetzt
mit der novelle des klimaschutzgesetzes
streben wir tiemann mit 2045 haben auch
sehr inszeniert ziele für das jahr 20 30
die mobilität die umgestaltung der
qualität
geht einher mit dem thema studieren man
kann die klimaschutzziele und das
erreichen der klimaschutzziele dafür
nutzen gleichzeitig die mobilität
eigentlich noch komfortabler zu
gestalten weil zum beispiel man weniger
vom pkw abhängig dass man mit der wagen
zwar eingegangen weil sie parallel
ausgebaut wird sehr stark bis zum jahr
20 30 12 spielen aber eine sehr hohe
profitiert hat ex niemals
klimaschutzziele aus dem
klimaschutzgesetz für das jahr 2021 hat
der verkehrssektor gerissen obwohl
geringer war kann in die bedingt im jahr
20 21 das heißt hier muss jetzt die
bundesregierung ein sofortprogramm für
den klimaschutz vorlegen bis mitte juli
um zu zeigen mit welchen merken
herr puls was muss ihrer meinung nach
der das hauptkriterium sein können wir
uns funktioniert das wenn wir sagen
klimaschutz sowie frau zimmer das sagt
muss sozusagen der haupt das
hauptkriterium sein oder wonach würden
sie die klimapolitik verkehrspolitik
ausrichten
naja das klimaschutzziel ist natürlich
ein extern gesetztes ziel und an dem
kommen wir nicht vorbei ich denke aber
natürlich auch dass das erhalten herr
mobilität in deutschland
eigentlich gleichwertig zu behandeln ist
gerade auch wenn wir hier aus einer
verkehrspolitischen debatte kommt ich
möchte da vielleicht noch mal auf 12
punkte
eingehen zum einen müssen wir glaube ich
noch mal ganz müssen wir mal ganz klar
sagen der verkehr wird nach allen
prognosen die wir haben bis 2050 nicht
weniger werden der personenverkehr wird
sich vielleicht verändern in der
errichtung dass die bahn schneller
erwachsen soll als die strafe dass die
bahn schneller wachsen soll dass der pkw
vom mgv also vom eigenen pkw vielleicht
weggeht zu carsharing und so weiter aber
insbesondere beim güterverkehr gehen wir
alle davon aus dass das noch spürbar
mehr werden wird also die
herausforderung an dieser stelle wird
nicht weniger und wenn wir uns mal die
verkehrsprognosen anschauen dann die
masse des klimaschutz effektes den wir
erzielen können wollen müssen muss
darüber kommen dass wir den
straßenverkehr dekarbonisierung
natürlich auch muss die bahn schneller
wachsen als die straße das schädlich
infrage um diese ziele erreichen zu
können aber wir dürfen uns nicht der
illusion hingeben dass das
mobilitätsbedürfnis der menschen in den
nächsten jahren schrumpfen wird da
spricht momentan nichts
und was wäre dann das könnte man das du
auf wie könnte man das
mobilitätsverhalten also der autofahrer
deeg organisieren
es gibt da jetzt natürlich die
verschiedenen ansätze einen ansatz der
massiv verfolgt wird ist ja die
elektrifizierung am ende geht eine
dekarbonisierung ftd forcierung des
verkehrs nur darüber dass ich ihn auf
strom um stelle deshalb ist es teil der
energiewende da ist natürlich dann ganz
entscheidend dass sich die
schnittstellen zum stromsektor
verbessere vulgo ladeinfrastruktur für
elektroautos
auch bei der bahn sind das ja immer noch
themen wo er auch noch dieselloks fahren
also da ist viel zu tun aber wir werden
glaube ich auch generell ganz großes
problem bekommen
abseits noch von den langen
planungszeiten er schon angesprochen
wurden da vielleicht noch mal warum eine
durchschnittszahl zu sagen die
schieneninfrastruktur völliger neubau
eines spielen weges dauert 20 jahre plus
bisher und großteil davon geht für die
planung darauf dass wir 2045
klimaneutral sein wollen und da nicht
schneller werden dann sind wir schon
verdammt kurz vor ultimo und ein
weiterer punkt den wir auch nicht außer
acht lassen dürfen im mobilitäts
prognosen sagen uns wie gesagt alles
wird personenverkehr wird ungefähr
gleich bleiben güterverkehr wird
mehreren wir müssen uns auch mal die
frage stellen wer fährt das eigentlich
in der zukunft lokführer sind schon
heute sind heute schon nicht mehr zu
kriegen bus und bahn straßenbahnfahrer
der ist es auch nicht möglich die
nachfrage heute zu decken das sind die
punkte auf die wir auch ganz deutlich
achten müssen wir brauchen auch die
leute die den verkehr stehen ich habe er
aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz auch bei
der frage wenn wir die klimaziele
erreichen wollen heute dann gibt es
natürlich genug ideen dann gibt es die
frage ist ein tempolimit dann gibt's die
frage nach autofreien sonntagen dazu gab
es denn diese woche eine petition im
bundestag wo klar gesagt wurde wir
müssten jetzt mal auf das tempolimit
setzen gerade weil wir im moment mit
diesen hohen energiekosten aber wir
unabhängig werden wollen auch von
lieferungen aus russland also warum ist
die fdp nicht für ein tempolimit also
ich glaube sie haben es ja gerade auch
russland energielieferung angesprochen
der prozentsatz
den man da ein spart bei
an russischem erdöl ist glaube ich
0,4 oder 0,5 bei tempo 130 und da ist
das angepasste verfahren der menschen
aktuell in diesem land noch nicht noch
nicht eingepreist und
ich glaube ein großteil der menschen für
die
ähnlich viel schneller und ist ja auch
keiner gezwungen mindestens auf der
autobahn kann man schneller fahren als
120 103 ja aber es ist ja auch kein
mensch gezwungen sein fahrverhalten
anzupassen ich kenne in meinem
freundeskreis viele viele menschen die
sagen auch aktuell angesichts der
aktuellen spritpreise ich fahre deutlich
zurückhaltender defensiver fahren nicht
schneller als 130 oder 140 und ich
glaube dass es
eine debatte die das problem auch was
der puls angesprochen hat in die
dekarbonisierung des
individualverkehrs nicht in ansätzen
lösen kann sondern dass wird ich sage
mal gerne als symbol für alles mögliche
herhalten aber hessen tank rabatt auch
das ist ein teil der entlastungspaket es
das tanken billiger werden soll bzw mal
bekommt einen zuschuss dafür das ist ja
mit dem neuen euro
ticket noch auch einen teil hilft das
wenn man sagt man will die verkehrswende
haben ja aber ich sage mal der tank
rabatt dient ja nicht nur ich sage mal
zwar auch den vielen pendlerinnen und
pendlern die täglich auf das auto
angewiesen sind aber da sind ja die die
handwerker die die ganzen spediteure die
unter enormen druck stehen weil auch
aufgrund des ukraine krieges die
lieferkette nähe angespannt sind die
natürlich auch die die gestiegenen
spritpreise nicht
sofort eins zu eins an ihre kunden
weitergeben können da darf man jetzt
nicht nur aufhalten kriegen ja alles
kriegen ja nicht nur die handwerker man
könnte ja dann sagen man gibt es dann
nur gezielt den menschen die es
vielleicht mehr brauchen als andere ja
aber irgendwann versinken sie bei so
einer sache in so einem bürokratie wisst
dass ich dann schon der meinung bin man
macht jetzt drei monate für alle genauso
wie wir das mit den neuen euro ticket
machen eine maßnahme die ich auch sehr
begrüße kann man auch sagen braucht
nicht jeder
also insofern beim tempolimit hält haben
sie sich nicht durchsetzen können wir
den koalitionsverhandlungen weil die fdp
das nicht wollte wenn sie alleine
regieren würden würden sie es einführen
wie sehen von halten sie
glaube die position der bündnisgrüne
styling hinlänglich bekannt ja wir
finden das gut und genauso wie es
geschrieben haben koalitionsverhandlung
haben wir uns da anders geeinigt
deswegen ist es für diese legislatur mit
einem generellen tempolimit wenn da
nicht irgendwo meinungswechsel erfolgt
ist das nicht hat sich die situation
geändert wir haben noch mal eine ganz
andere diskussion durch den ukraine
krieg über unsere energie liefern ist es
ein forum wo sie sagen da müssten wir
eigentlich jetzt noch mal versuchen ja
nachzubessern nachzuschärfen ich sag mal
so ist es eine potenzielle maßnahme in
einem strauß von maßnahmen wir hoffen
dass jetzt vom verkehrsministerium ja in
dieser frist zum klimaschutz
sofortprogramme neben dort ein bündel an
maßnahmen vorgelegt wird da putzt mich
jetzt überraschen wenn das tempolimit
dabei wäre dann aber
und darauf kommt oft sage ich mal für
ihn ist es wichtig dass man sich nach
dafür ein dass es dafür ein natürlich
wird darüber geredet aber der
koalitionsvertrag den wir jetzt nicht an
der stelle ad acta legen sag ich mal ne
so und trotzdem ist die meinung der
grünen bekannt und natürlich fragen wir
auch mal wieder nach ohne haken danach
ich sag mal so ich würde aber nicht nur
auf dieses eine diesen einen punkt
setzen sondern da reden wir auch über
home office da reden wir über ja
natürlich bepreisung und so weiter und
so weiter und so weiter überhaupt
besseres bei anlagen gut wie was ihm
schon getan haben ich würde aber
trotzdem ganz kurz nach einem einen
kleinen sanften widerspruch oder
vielleicht ein anderes andere
formulierung oder eine fragestellung
noch mal rein bringen zum thema
mobilität und der zukunft ja das
mobilitätsbedürfnis der deutschen wird
jetzt nicht sinken warum auch ganze
gegenteil man kann sogar sagen dass bei
einigen menschen das mobilitätsbedürfnis
wirklich erfüllt ist aber wie eine armut
an der stelle haben kinder die sich
deutlich weniger frei bewegen können in
stetten ältere menschen auf dem land die
nur mit dem auto und irgendwann geht es
nicht mehr dann müssen wir nacharbeiten
und das muss jetzt kommen so da war
durchaus mehr mobilität entstehen weil
ich erwarte dass man weniger mobilität
hat beim realität weniger weniger mehr
mobilität bei weniger verkehr das ist
damals noch hinkommen wenn man es nicht
so bei mobil sein will jeder ist eine
form von freiheit verkehr mal keiner
also auch gern mal keiner am ende des
tages weil das hingegen widerspruch das
klingt ein bisschen wieder hin wie ein
widerspruch aber jetzt weiß dass in
einem auto regelmäßig eine person drin
sitzt dann weiß man wo ich viel
potenzial da noch ist so und das thema
sharing ist ja schon angesprochen worden
fahrzeuge stehen regelmäßig 23 23
stunden am tag selbst und krassesten
stau sieht man eine eigene wohnstraße
noch ganz viele autos stehen also nur da
ist potenzial nach oben ich war darauf
verändert hinaus beim thema cargo oder
transport von gütern
waren da ist müssen die spannende frage
ob das wirklich so kommt wie die
prognosen das so sagen weil wir gerade
zum beispiel einmal das thema
lieferkette ganz neu anschauen will man
das eigentlich auch so unsere zweite
muss man sich die sinnfrage stellen wir
sind in deutschland eine extrem reichen
gesellschaft weltweit verglichen und das
sollte immer noch mehr werden so also
pro monat anlage gewonnen da ist die
wachstumsrate dahinter wollen wir nicht
in reich bereich der dienstleistung
eingehen da ein bisschen uns neu
justieren ich glaube da wäre es viel
segen drauf trotzdem geht es ja jetzt
konkret um die menschen die jetzt
sozusagen im stau stehen oder halt eben
mit dem ziemlich weit oben auf dem land
nicht weiter kommen vorzimmer wie
sinnvoll ist da ist ja wie sinnvoll
finden sie ein tempolimit und wie
sinnvoll finden sie dann auch einen tank
rabatt weil das sind die sachen die
diskutiert worden und es ging natürlich
grundsätzlich um die entlastung aber
gleichzeitig sollen damit auch dann
er soll versucht werden hat eben denen
auch den co2 austausch zu mindern
also zunächst ein tempolimit tempolimit
hat ja nicht nur den vorteil dass man
damit sofort benzin sparen kann meines
wissens nach zahlen des
umweltbundesamtes dann auch im bereich
um 0 3 prozent kraftstoff einsparen die
damenwelt reduktion von der abhängigkeit
vom erdöl und parken wir haben
klimaschutzeffekt aber vor eigentlich
verbesserte verkehrssicherheit und
rettet menschenleben wie eigentlich fast
alle anderen mehr alle anderen männer
haben ein thermoelement
alle
oecd-länder haben ein tempolimit in
deutschland ist mittlerweile die
mehrheit für ein tempolimit
aus diesem gesichtspunkt
zügig umgesetzt werden auch deutschen
aufgebracht wobei heute jemand ist wird
ja niemand das wird ja niemand gezwungen
schneller zu fahren wir heute sagt man
kann ja jeder für sich kann ja sein
eigenes tempo limit sozusagen anwenden
die frage ist nur ob diejenigen die
durch fahrzeug
sehr sehr schnell fragen auf deren
fragen möglicherweise ihr leben lassen
ob ihr dann auch noch so überall haben
okay aber nochmals zu den klimaschutz
fragen instrumenten also was mir wichtig
ist es nochmals betonen das erreichen
der klimaschutzziele muss nicht
automatisch einen wert geben mit einer
einschränkung der mobilität wir haben
letztes jahr eine studie veröffentlicht
thema 92 deutschland wo wir aus gezeigt
haben dass das ziel erreichbar ist ohne
einschränkung der mobilität nimmt in dem
meer verlagert wird vom pkw-verkehr auf
den öffentlichen personennahverkehr
ausbauen mehr mit dem rad betragen sonst
muss gegangen wird und herrn gelb
angesagt ist einfach aufhöre ausgelastet
waren ja also längst
von zarten und der rest der noch aus
pkw und lkw transportieren wird kann in
diesem zeitraum auf elektrifiziert das
heißt klimaschutzziele sind erstens
erreichbar und zweitens
auch ohne einschränkungen bei der
bewegungs- und den sie gerade gesprochen
habe haben die frage wie sinnvoll ist es
gerade wenn man eigentlich einen
riesigen schritt und ganz schnellen
schritt nach vorne machen muss was im
klimaschutz im verkehrssektor angehen um
die ziele 20 30 20 45 noch zu erreichen
die energie steuern zu senken
da setzt man ganz klares signal und man
gibt viel geld aus um dann irgendwie
kraftstoff hin zu machen die in zukunft
eigentlich auch teurer werden sollten
fossile kraftstoffe um anreize für ein
klimafreundliches mobilitätsverhalten zu
schaffen herr puls wie sehen sie ist wie
wichtig ist es für die ja auch für die
wirtschaft auch für heute und eben von
den handwerkern gesprochen von all denen
dass man da jetzt eine entlastung
schafft dass man jetzt eben so dass man
diesen tank rabatt gibt macht das sinn
naja
dieselpreise sind natürlich gerade im
güterverkehr und auch im gewerblichen
verkehr ein riesen thema zurzeit wir
haben einen unglaublichen
preissprung erlebt wie wir ihn
eigentlich noch nie hatten und das ist
natürlich auch ein ordentlicher treiber
für die inflation sie uns gerade
umtreibt
ich persönlich denke dass eine
entlastung in richtung gewerbe diese auf
jeden fall diskutabel wäre so wie es
jetzt läuft wie es jetzt angelegt ist
ist es mir persönlich vielleicht ein
bisschen zu breit muss ich sagen aber es
ist gerade im gewerblichen bereich ein
riesenthema dass firmen dass spediteure
quasi pleite gehen an den jetzigen
preisen weil sie lang laufende verträge
haben und ähnliches wir sind hier halt
auch wirklich in einer totalen
sondersituation seit kurzem das heißt
seit kurzem
eigentlich schon mit corona ist ja unser
verkehrt hat sind wir ja auf der suche
nach einem new normal also das thema
home office wurde ja schon angesprochen
oder das was wir gerade machen dass wir
nicht alle in berlin sind das war vor
corona quasi eine ausnahme situation
also ich persönlich bin auch mal
gespannt wie wird sich das eigentlich
alles nach diesem schock corona jetzt
den kraftstoffpreis schock usw wie wird
sich das eigentlich wirklich alles ein
ruckeln und wie passt das eigentlich zu
den prognosen die wir bisher haben aber
und das sind ja auch maßnahmen sind ja
auch maßnahmen die auf drei monate
beschränkt sind und dann ist da die
frage danach geht es ja dann wieder
anders weiter das geht ja auch für das
neuen euro ticket herr reuter kommt es
jetzt eigentlich ist soll am freitag im
bundesrat abgestimmt werden und da sagen
jetzt bayern baden württemberg und
thüringen ich finde wir eigentlich nicht
so toll also wie sicher ist dass das es
ab erster juni kommt also ich gehe fest
davon aus
dass es zum ersten juni kommt wir haben
es morgen im bundestag und ich gehe auch
fest davon aus das ist eine deutliche
mehrheit im bundesrat finden wird am
freitag und ich bin auch der festen
überzeugung dass es auskömmlich
finanziert ist für die erste an die
länder sind würde nicht reichen die für
die bundesländer
alle berechnungen die auf das
ministerium festgestellt
und gemacht hat sagt die zweieinhalb
milliarden
plus die neuen euro pro ticket die ja
auch
dort verbleiben
in den bundesländern
das ist nicht bayern bremen und
thüringen
jetzt sagen sagen ist ästhetik erreichen
und insofern glaube ich dass
das passieren wir das geht ja jetzt auch
bei den bundesländern auch schon wieder
darum wir haben im koalitionsvertrag die
erhöhung der regionalisierungsmittel
allgemein jetzt unabhängig von dieser
sondermaßnahme verabredet dass man da
auch jetzt noch mal mit hinweis auf das
kommende jahr schon mal signalisiert wie
nötig das ist und dann steigen die
menschen in den zug er gelb sah und die
züge sind brechend voll und sagen das
mache ich nie mehr nach drei monaten ist
das eine befürchtung die sie haben
also in der tat wir müssen gucken dass
dann die unternehmen des lpv also bus
und bahn dort gut informieren gerade auf
welchen strecken es zu überlastungen
kommen könnte damit man sich eben darauf
einstellen kann seiner mobilität darauf
entsprechend dann hin optimiert
wenn man sich den einzigen kann ich ja
nicht reservieren da weiß ich ja gar
nicht wie viele leute da jetzt wirklich
kommen was ich in einem ic ja kann
glauben sie mal die unternehmen haben
eine gute ahnung vielleicht in der
ersten woche noch nicht ja das will ich
nicht nicht stören aber die wissen schon
was sie wann wo wir erwarten können man
kann auch an den auslastung
barometer habe ich mal sagen das sehr
gut ablesen also die sind nicht nur
google was das weiß sondern es ist auch
unser unternehmen und deswegen muss man
das sehr gut einfach immer wieder da
informieren damit die leute in die lage
versetzt werden können gute
entscheidungen zu treffen und ja
natürlich es wird das ist ein sehr
attraktives angebot und natürlich wird
werden dass wir hoffentlich viele leute
wahrnehmen und dann mag es auch mal zu
einem engpass kommen das zeigt aber nur
wo die stellschraube eben noch nicht
optimal ist wo wir auch dann eben mehr
an als
experiment um danach zu gucken also das
ist ein gewissen experimentellen
charakter hat ich muss mal und schon
zugestehen also was hatten wir glaube
ich in ganz europa noch nicht drei
monate mal quasi also so günstig und so
schnell es ist eine entlastungsmaßnahmen
wir versuchen es gerade
verkehrspolitisch aufzuladen aber auch
da es ist für alle es ist auch für die
menschen die es sich vielleicht gar
nicht die ist gar nicht brauchen ist das
zum einen sozial gerecht und wäre es
dann nicht sinnvoller zu sagen wir
machen so wie es in österreich ist in
wien ist ein ein euro ticket also ein
euro pro tag 365 euro im jahr und wir
legen das mal langfristig an weil nach
drei monaten ist dann alles wieder so
teuer wie zuvor lässt sich hören ja der
gedanke bei dieser sozialpolitische
maßnahme war ist soll schnell gehen das
war wirklich schnell gehen also nicht
irgendwie im oktober hat ausreichend
vorlaufzeit sondern jetzt sollen die
bürger in bürger entlastet werden jetzt
drückt der schuh das ist auch beim tank
rabatt genau der gleiche gedanke auch
dort kann man über die soziale
sinnhaftigkeit ein paar stellen stehe
ich warte sowie durchaus sehr intensiv
diskutieren und das lässt sich natürlich
auch beim neuen euro ticket durch
spielen aber es sollte schnell gehen da
muss man gewisse ungenauigkeiten
hinnehmen wenn man das machen will und
wir versuchen jetzt alles daran zu
setzen erst dass es kommt so und
zweitens dass wir dann auch eine essen
lernen daraus haben also wo hakt was
kann man besser machen und zum zweiten
natürlich ganz viele leute und das ist
glaube ich auch der impuls den die pnv
unternehmen jetzt setzen wollen ganz
viele leute mit dem öpnv raum mit bussen
bahnen in verbindung zu bringen menschen
die werden corona vielleicht auch
rausgegangen sind zurückzugewinnen zu
sagen hey kennt jedoch dass dann wäre es
dann ganz gut und natürlich wenn jetzt
quasi dort
dann unschönes passiert ist das
natürlich nicht hilfreich deswegen ist
das im wohlverstandenen eigeninteresse
dass da alles super ihren job machen das
ist anstrengend
obwohl es wie sinnvoll halten sie dass
das neue euro ticket für drei monate
denken sie ist das eine sinnvolle
maßnahme um mehr menschen wirklich wmv
zu begeistern oder könnte ist das
sozusagen könnte das auch genau nach
hinten losgehen wenn es nicht
funktioniert
na ja wir haben das ähnlich ist ja schon
mal gehabt mit dem schöne wochenend
ticket vor im jahr 1995
da konnte man dann für 15 mag
mit fünf personen quasi unbegrenzt
regionalzug fahren das war insofern sehr
erfolgreich dass sehr viele leute in
dieses ticket gekauft haben
sehr stark allerdings konzentriert
auftritt auch auf dann touristisch
interessanten strecken die befürchtungen
über sylt geäußert wurden die kommen
erfahrung
also
da haben wir schon ein paar
erfahrungswerte das kann durchaus
funktionieren gerade in den
sommermonaten glaube ich schon dass das
ganz gut angenommen wird aber wir müssen
uns auch bewusst sein wenn wir die
kapazitäten langfristig ausbauen wollen
und der unterschied zwischen 1995 und
heute ist die züge sind heute voll
damals waren sie leer
deshalb konnte das ja eingeführt und wir
haben einen echten engpass bei den
leuten die wir unbedingt brauchen wenn
wir pnv und schienenverkehr stärken
wollen nämlich bei denen die dinge
erfahren heute schon bei lokführern mit
abstrichen auch bei busfahrern und
straßenbahnfahrer es gibt mehr offene
stellen als arbeitslos da wird es
verdammt schwierig die kapazität
kurzfristig zu steigen das ist ein
engpass dessen müssen wir uns bewusst
sein wenn wir erfolg haben mit dem
system ja also frau zimmer ist das ziel
mehr menschen in den op en v zu kriegen
eigentlich gar kein gutes weil man
letztendlich wenn alle jeden weiter auch
nach den drei monaten weiter fahren
wollen wenn das wenn man merkt das wird
gar nicht funktionieren
das
fir ist gut mehr menschen in gefahr zu
bringen wir haben gerade das beispiel
wie mit dem greifen nationen weltsicht
politik gedanken gesprochen
das ist geknackt und in wien die der
anteil der nutzung des öffentlichen
personennahverkehrs
vor allen dingen in dem moment stiegen
als das angebot deutlich verbessert
worden ist parallel die
parkraumbewirtschaftung
ausgebaut wurde und mit den
mehreinnahmen durch die parkraum
gesellschaft geschafft und wurde
wiederum des gleichen satz von 60 euro
ticket querfinanziert das a und o ist
wir müssen das angebot attraktiver
gestalten genau das was wir am anfang
angesprochen haben ja dass man nicht auf
den zug warteten nicht über das film
sind es nun gute takt und jetzt unter
guter anbindung an den öpnv und wenn das
geschafft ist dann sollte man
gleichgewicht zwischen bus bahn und pkw
in uns umgekehrt stellen jetzt die drei
monate das ist jetzt öfter gleich ein
spannendes experiment alle wir freuen
uns darauf ihn zu beobachten
durch ja ich finde das kann man auch mal
positiv
aufladen das thema das ist ein
ganz tolles angebot was die
was die bundesregierung was die ampel
koalition jetzt den menschen macht
natürlich kann man da immer haare in der
suppe finden aber ich glaube das schafft
stefanie elpers gesagt auf vielleicht
viele anreize für für die menschen in
ihrem in unserem land auf den
öffentlichen personen nahverkehr
umzusteigen oder wieder zurück zu
gewinnen weil der großteil gerade die
berufspendler fahren ja auch nicht im
ics sondern in regionalzügen und da
müssen wir glaube ich
ein anderes experiment kennen wir aus
den 70er jahren das waren die autofreien
sonntage beim preisschock damals wäre
das nicht eine sache wo man sagt ja wir
können ja vielleicht mal ein bisschen
kreativer werden weil es geht ja immer
um bei dass mobilität und co2 ausstoß
verringern hergebe wir sind das so sagen
auch da gab es ja im wunsch von einer
gruppe menschen die eine petition
geschrieben haben hier auch gesagt haben
auch das wäre mal sinnvoll gerade im
moment also zuerst
70er jahre
boston globe da war es irgendwie nicht
so das klima für euch weise nicht
genommen als aktionist verkehrsaufkommen
nicht ganz so dass das kommt noch dazu
vielleicht nicht ja zunächst das auto
verkehrsaufkommen war dadurch gehen ja
trotzdem ist das natürlich eine maßnahme
die wir auch kennen also wir kennen alle
die europäische woche der mobilität wo
ein tag autofrei probiert werden soll
wir haben im juni regelmäßigen tag wo
das probiert werden sondern natürlich
ist das eine idee die man da auch mal
durchspielen kann
aber noch mal es geht nicht um die
einzelnen maßnahmen müssen dauerhaft bei
den co2 emissionen runter und da
brauchen wir ja den technologischen
fortschritt ak antriebs wende so und sie
muss schnell passieren damit sie schnell
irgendwo muss viel getan werden wir
brauchen sicherlich maßnahmen wie home
office und dann bin ich sehr gespannt
was vom verkehrsministerium kommt was
hat sofort und schnell wirkt das hätte
sie es ist ja nicht 120 die was wäre
eine forderung von ihnen als fdp
geführte verkehrsministerium gerade auf
es geht ja zum beispiel auch bei ihm war
das immer gemeinsam dass sie kennen ja
mal so aus varel förderung von e-autos
zum beispiel also und das hat er
deswegen noch am gleichen tag dann
korrigiert so
war die kommunikation nicht ganz
glücklich muss man so gestehen aber wo
holt wird da fallen späne ich hoffe es
reichlich gehobelt weil es wichtig sagt
das ist nicht und für die wir haben zehn
jahre beim klimaschutz gefühlt als
deutschland 8 auf der stelle gestanden
die müssen jetzt sektor eben die nicht
im verkehrssektor insbesondere im
verkehrssektor und im gebäudesektor das
sind die baustellen wo wir jetzt quasi
im den kick start modus loslegen müssen
und es dass das klimaschutzgesetz was da
auch quasi den zeitlichen rahmen setzt
ist ja noch nicht mal von uns ja also
von amd sondern ist eine von der großen
koalition und jetzt da auch das
verkehrssystem wir schon gehörig unter
druck was ja jetzt auch logisch ist weil
ihm die bedingungen die
rahmenbedingungen klimaschutz und wie
die welt sich entwickelt ebenso sind wie
sie sind so und deswegen brauchen wir
dass viele schlaue vorschläge und wenn
das verkehrsministerium der andere
vorschläge hat die eben nicht so das ist
ja ein freiheits angriff ein paar
stellen also wenn man dann eben eine
gewisse art der mobilität festgelegt
wird dass ein freiheitsgewinn für andere
menschen da sind aber auch nicht
vergessen also bewusst zum beispiel ist
geführt
jede woche oder im monat einmal die
autobahn gesperrt und das ist total
interessant bastian da passiert was die
leute damit machen mit diesen freiraum
so ob das in deutschland ein gangbarer
denkbarer blick ist dann könnte man ja
kreativ sein also aber das ist immer
bleiben wir da noch mal bei den e autos
wie gesagt die frage halt eben sollten
jetzt am ersten juli 20 21 vor einem
jahr hatten wir deutschland 440.000
e-autos und ende 2030 sollen es 15
millionen seien also wie wird das
funktionieren
ein ganz wichtiger punkt ist der ausbau
der ladeinfrastruktur
auch das irgendwie schon seit vielen
jahr und da laufen ja jetzt die
ausschreibung sowohl bei den autobahn
aber es ist natürlich auch ganz ganz
ganz wichtig in den städten in den
gemeinden vor ort dass da wenn ich mit
den bürgermeistern bei mir im wahlkreis
sprechen und sie darauf ansprechen egal
welches parteibuch der ladeinfrastruktur
ja da haben wir es vor der sparkassen
und vom rathaus 2 und vom
einkaufszentrum auch noch zwei so und
dann wird schon weniger wohngebieten
ganz zu schweigen nicht jeder hat in
einfamilienhaus mit der auffahrt wurde
war box dran schrauben kann sondern wir
müssen da massiv und das tut er jetzt
die ampelkoalition die infrastruktur
ausbauen und diskriminierungsfrei
erreichbar sein und dann steigen die
leute auch aus dem auto aus e auto und
wenn sie überall und sich ordentliche
zuschüsse kriegen das ist endlich auch
ein anreiz so die förderprogramme werden
ja weiter laufen natürlich muss man da
auch genau schauen dass man da nicht
überdreht dass die leute dann auch im
halben jahr das auto mit gewinnen ins
ausland verkaufen das sollte jetzt nicht
an reiz eines förderprogrammes sein
sondern da muss man sich genau anschauen
wie die förderkulisse
auszusehen hat ja herr puls was denken
sie wenn man sagt förderung e mobilität
da ist sich die ampel koalition einig
was heißt das weil das sagen ja dann
nach wie vor viele das würde doch eine
menge ja folgen auch dann doch für
unsere autoindustrie haben oder müssen
wir sagen die sind inzwischen so
umgestellt das ist überhaupt keine
gefahr
keine gefahr ist vielleicht das fall ist
vielleicht der falsche ausdruck aber die
branche ist dabei sich zu wandeln und da
das wird nicht in deutschland
entschieden wie sie sich wandelt also
der der zug ist am fahren keine frage
ich denke aber für diese ziele die wir
für unsere bestands flotte haben also
die 14 millionen 15 millionen für 2030
haben sollen da wird in der tat auch
wenn es etwas abgedroschen klingt die
ladeinfrastruktur die zentrale rolle
spielen momentan ist es ja so dass 80 90
prozent der ladevorgänge bei den nutzern
zu hause stattfinden oder auf der arbeit
aber wenn wir auf die 14 15 millionen
kommen wollen und perspektivisch bis
2045 müssten wir ja eigentlich eher auf
100 prozent des bestandes kommen gerade
beim pkw dann müssen wir auch den
laternenparker einfangen oder denjenigen
kein eigenes haus hat aber sondern eine
tiefgarage und der wird dann künftig auf
eine öffentliche ladeinfrastruktur
angewiesen sein aber es geht ja auch
noch weiter als weitere alternativen
wären zum beispiel biokraftstoffe der
zweiten generation die erste generation
soll der ca nach initiative des
landwirtschafts- und des
umweltministeriums möglichst schnell
raus aus dem bestand oder
künstliche synthetische kraftstoffe oder
wasserstoff und so weiter auch hier
landen wer dann tatsächlich wieder bei
dem abgedroschenen thema planungszeiten
dann das produktionskapazitäten für
solche kraftstoffe zu bauen auch das
dauert verdammt lange na ja also ich
deutschland wir sind nicht mehr so
silver bullet in the barrel haben jetzt
hat sondern werden müssen wir müssen
einen mix kriegen wir müssen den mix
kriegen vielen dank herr puls und frau
zimmer wir sind am ende dieser sendung
ja und heute obwohl wir natürlich noch
ganz viel zu besprechen hätten und 1
natürlich mitnehmen wir müssen schneller
planen und irgendwie muss alles ein
bisschen schneller gehen aber ich glaube
wir brauchen erstmal auch viel geduld
und bestimmt im sommer wenn das nur ein
euro ticket dann kommt das war unsere
sendung zur mobilität wende machen das
gut
[Musik]